und jetzt das heute journal mit hanna
zimmermann und christian sievers
guten abend hinein wir beginnen mit
einem satz der klingt wie aus einem
schönen traum die dänen haben ihn schon
vor ein paar tagen gehört von ihrer
ministerpräsidentin die dann ab heute so
gut wie alle corona regeln aufgehoben
hat wir sagen auf wiedersehen zu den
beschränkungen und willkommen zu dem
leben das wie vor kohle hatten
wie die pandemie begonnen hat das ist
uns allen schmerzhaft klar wie sie endet
ist so zeigt das beispiel unserer
nachbarn im norden nicht nur eine frage
die virologen entscheiden es ist eine
politische frage bei der die regierenden
auch ein risiko übernehmen die
offizielle zahl der neuen infektionen in
dänemark ist aktuell über vier mal so
hoch wie bei uns aber das soll jetzt
nicht mehr entscheiden cupid 19 gilt
seit heute in dänemark offiziell nicht
mehr als
gesellschaftskritische krankheit dara
hassanzadeh über einen großen schritt
und wie der in deutschland gesehen wird
prost auf das ende der korona
beschränkung in dänemark keine masken
pflicht mehr keine abstandsregeln keine
im pfund test nachweise erschweren das
nachtleben in kopenhagen und das gefällt
den meisten denen
ich bin gerade 18 geworden deshalb ist
das hier ein totales plus das stadt
wieder geöffnet ist dass man mit seinen
freunden raus und was trinken gehen kann
einfach mit leuten zusammen sein
man kann sich schon vorstellen dass die
zahlen jetzt noch ziemlich steigen
könnten wenn alles offen ist aber ich
glaube das ist unter kontrolle
und damit ist sie nicht allein laut
umfragen begrüßt eine deutliche mehrheit
der dänen den wegfall der korona
beschränkungen und das trotz rasant
steigender neuinfektionen gegenläufig
ist aber die entwicklung bei der
belegung von intensivbetten grund für
den dänischen optimismus dort sind mehr
als 60 prozent dreifach geimpft dazu war
ein viertel der dänen an corona erkrankt
fast herdenimmunität
generell sind wir gut darin gewesen
schnell zu reagieren wenn es schlechte
nachrichten gab
als man ende november aus südafrika von
omikron hörte haben wir in dänemark und
in anderen europäischen ländern schnell
restriktionen eingeführt
gleichzeitig finde ich aber auch dass
wir gut und schnell auf die positiven
nachrichten reagieren sollten
in deutschland geschieht dies nur in
kleinen schritten wie in bremen dort
dürfen am nächsten samstag 10.000 fans
ins weser stadion gehen damit begibt
sich bremens bürgermeister fast in eine
vorreiterrolle wir würden es gibt einen
unterschied zwischen schwarz und weiß
nämlich auch grautöne das eine ist zu
sagen wir bleiben immer in einem zustand
wo wir die pandemie so fürchten dass wir
gar nie zu unserem normalen leben
zurückkehren die andere möglichkeit wäre
wie das jetzt in denen praktizieren wir
lassen alle beschränkungen fahren und
sagen wir erklären jetzt die pandemie
für beendet
ich finde es vernünftig da im mittelweg
zu gehen zu sagen wir brauchen öffnungs
perspektiven
was deutschland aber von dänemark
unterscheidet sind die recht vielen
ungeimpften älteren ein schwer
kalkulierbares risiko für die intensiv
medizin davor warnen die gegner von
lockerungen
brechen jetzt keine exit-strategie
debatte vom zaun das wäre völlig
unangemessen und ein völlig falsches
signal
ob falsch oder richtig das signal der
dänischen politik ist zumindest klar und
eindeutig ja in dänemarks geschäften
werden also die korona hinweise entfernt
bars clubs konzerte wir haben es gesehen
alles geht wieder die regierung guckt
nicht mehr auf impf nachweise und
testungen sie macht einen gewaltigen
schritt und nimmt risiko in kauf gucken
wir auf deutschland statt einer guten
namen nach berlin am 16 februar ist die
nächste ministerpräsidentenkonferenz das
ist ja immer so ein datum auf dienstag
für alle gucken wie ist denn die
generelle tendenz ist so eine umfassende
öffnung auch in deutschland denkbar also
sicher noch nicht zu dieser nächsten
konferenz und wahrscheinlich auch nicht
in den direkten wochen danach dazu gehen
die meinungen bei denen die darüber
entscheiden müssen einfach zu weit
auseinander
ganz grob gesagt kann man momentan
aufteilen in das team vorsicht und in
ein team nach vorne schauen zum team
vorsicht gehört unter anderem der
bundeskanzler aber auch bundesländer wie
zum beispiel thüringen die er bei der
letzten sitzung noch gesagt haben wir
sollten sogar noch mehr möglichkeiten
haben zu verschärfen wenn es denn
unbedingt sein muss zum team nach vorne
schauen gehört markus söder der bremer
bürgermeister bovenschulte dem wir
gerade im beitrag auch gehört haben aber
auch finanzminister christian lindner
die sagen man sollte doch vielleicht
schon mal darüber nachdenken wie man
eine rückkehr zur normalität vorbereiten
kann was beide gruppen eint ist dass sie
nicht jetzt schon alle maßnahmen
aufheben wollen das auch nicht in
nächster zeit sehen weil sie eben doch
zu große sorgen vor den auswirkungen von
omikron haben wahrscheinlicher ist eine
diskussion über einen schrittweisen
ausstieg wenn die zahlen sich weiterhin
moderat entwickeln die krankenhäuser
nicht überlastet werden und auch in den
kritischen infrastrukturen die situation
weiter entspannt bleibt ich habe unser
land wir leben gleich noch ein bisschen
weiter denn in deutschland knirscht es
derweil bei einem ganz zentralen projekt
der regierung zur pandemie bekämpfung
nämlich der impfpflicht für alle die in
medizinischen und in pflegeberufen
arbeiten die also mit den verwundbarsten
zu tun haben mit denen die besonders zu
schützen sind diese partielle
impfpflicht sollte ab dem 16 märz
durchgesetzt werden bis dann sollten
alle diese beschäftigten einen nachweis
vorgelegt haben jetzt wird klar so
konsequent wie gedacht wird das nicht
passieren
viele gesundheitsämter hatten gewarnt
sie könnten das nicht umsetzen und jetzt
können die sich laut
gesundheitsministerium doch mehr zeit
lassen bernd mosebach berichtet
altenpflegeheim st hedwig in wittenburg
seit fünf jahren kümmert sich stefanie
prosa um damen wie um gottschick
76 alte menschen 72 mitarbeitende 13
davon sind bisher nicht geimpft stefan
poser zu
sie wird sich nicht impfen lassen auch
nicht bis zum 16 märz wenn die
impfpflicht gesetz wird zurzeit werden
die dienstpläne für die nächsten beiden
monate erstellt für die heimleitung
einblick ins ungewisse schon heute ist
das personal knapp und wenn jetzt noch
weitere mitarbeiter ausfallen dann sind
diese nicht so ohne weiteres
einzustellen es gibt auf dem freien
arbeitsmarkt kaum eine fachkraft die
arbeit zu im norden der größten stadt
des landes hat rostocks seinen im
stützpunkt aufgeschlagen das
gesundheitsamt organisiert hier die
impfkampagne der freiwilligen künftig
müssen die mitarbeiter die impfpflicht
durchsetzen letzte woche hatten die
kommunen und landkreise im nordosten
gewarnt zu wenig personal die regeln
unklar die herausforderung zu groß wir
müssen uns am beispiel von herrn müller
zu machen prüfen ist herr müller aus
medizinischen gründen die wir für
akzeptabel halten nicht geimpft wenn das
nicht der fall ist müssen wir
entscheiden ob ein bußgeld oder ein
zwangsgeld verordnet wird und wir müssen
darüber entscheiden ob ein
betretungsverbot für seine einrichtungen
der erarbeitet ausgesprochen wird
außerdem müssen wir prüfen ob in der
einrichtung die versorgungssicherheit
gefährdet ist wenn herr müller nicht zur
arbeit kommt wenn sie gefährdet ist
müssen wir alternativen entwickeln die
landesregierung hat hilfe zugesagt
software in vier wochen für alle
gesundheitsämter orientierung und
personal
vor allem einen handlungsleitfaden an
die hand zu geben für einfache für
normale für schnell zu regeln gefälle es
wird aber auch juristisch schwierige
dinge geben die dann eben auch personell
gut und ersetzt werden müssen sicherlich
auch mit juristen
betretungsverbot für impfwillige oder
sie gewähren lassen im st hedwig
altenpflegeheim steht für das
gesundheitsamt diese entscheidung an in
13 fällen ich würde in diesem falle alle
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter gern
behalten ich werde schätze sie alle also
auch alle ungeimpfte wobei ich natürlich
ganz klar sagen muss also ich bin
natürlich für das impfen weil das immer
schon vielen menschen das leben gerettet
hat mit der berufsbezogenen impfpflicht
verliert nicht jeder impfwillige
automatisch seinen job hat die
bundesregierung heute klar gestellt die
einrichtungen müssten auch einsatzfähig
bleiben da kommt einiges zu auf die
gesundheitsämter
statt einem klaren stichtag jetzt also
neue ausnahmen damit ist die impfpflicht
für pflegeberufe nicht gescheit hat aber
es zeigt sich schon bei diesem jahr
verhältnismäßig kleinen teil von
betroffenen wie viele schwierigkeiten
die umsetzung macht stark und aller
werden da jetzt auch zweifel laut wie
das dann erst bei einer impfpflicht für
alle werden könnte das wird mit
sicherheit diskutiert werden und es
stärkt auf jeden fall denen den rücken
die von anfang an gesagt haben eine
allgemeine impfpflicht geht nur dann
wenn sie nicht nur auf dem papier gut
aussieht sondern in der realität auch
umsetzbar ist also im wahren leben
funktioniert und diese stimmen gibt es
in allen parteien die sich an der
diskussion beteiligen das jetzt bei der
teil- impfpflicht tatsächlich ist schon
zu einem solchen durcheinander gekommen
ist und dann auch zu einer großen
unsicherheit das ist kein gutes
vorzeichen egal für welche variante es
gibt ja mehrere dieser diskutiert werden
es wird ja nur größer das problem wenn
man ehrlich impfpflicht anwenden möchte
zum beispiel auf alle ab 18 sowie
urlaubs favorisiert oder auch gestaffelt
wie friedrich merz ist heute für die
union vorgestellt hat je mehr menschen
involviert sind desto schwieriger die
umsetzung desto schwieriger die
kontrolle wenn man sich nicht noch
einmal eine solche pleite erlauben will
dann muss man jetzt jeden
gesetzesvorschlag der vorgelegt wird auf
herz und nieren prüfen und das bringt
auf jeden fall den zeitplan man sich
vorgenommen hat noch einmal ins wanken
interessante erläuterungen frontaler
banerjee zdf berlin vielen dank und der
deutsche arbeitsmarkt hatte corona
weitgehend weggesteckt das ist die
überraschende nachricht heute aus
nürnberg die zahl der arbeitslosen ist
fast wieder auf dem niveau wie vor
corona die aussichten für jobsuchende
sind wieder so gut wie vorher in den
tiefen der statistik stecken aber noch
zwei weitere wichtige entwicklungen die
nachfrage nach kurzarbeit ist wieder
gestiegen der leichtere zugang zum
kurzarbeitergeld soll noch mal
verlängert werden und in der pandemie
haben sich ganze branchen völlig neu
orientieren müssen da ist etwas enorm in
bewegung geraten wie isabel de la vega
jetzt zeigt fahrzeug check beim
rettungsdienst in frankfurt chris freier
macht seit einem dreiviertel jahr eine
ausbildung zum notfallsanitäter der 23
jährige ist gelernter koch mit guten
karrierechancen doch dann kam corona und
freie entschied mit einer anderen lehre
noch mal ganz von vorne anzufangen
es ging mir um die sicherheit die
treffer sind in kurzarbeit rang direkt
aber auch genau und hab dann einen job
sucht ruhe ist sarah ich möchte diesen
auf dauer ausüben und auf dauer
gesichert haben und den habe ich dem
rettungsfonds die pandemie verändert den
arbeitsmarkt ein viertel aller
mitarbeiter hat der gastronomie den
rücken gekehrt und ist in andere
branchen abgewandert
johannes götzen arbeitet bei einem
masken hersteller auch er hat im
vergangenen jahr beruflich einen harten
schnitt gemacht vom erfolgreichen
tontechniker für große konnte zerrte und
veranstaltungen zum mitarbeiter eines
unternehmens für medizintechnik
mittlerweile hat er die vorzüge des
neuen jobs mit familien verträglichen
arbeitszeiten schätzen gelernt so sind
viele die
nicht mehr zurückkommen weil auch klar
ist in unserer branche ist das
monatliche einkommen existiert werden
viele zahlen ersten vier wochen viele
zahlen überhaupt nicht und mir hast du
jeden monat ein gehalt viele tausend
mitarbeiter haben die
veranstaltungsbranche in den vergangenen
zwei jahren verlassen wenn die pandemie
abflacht werden diese beschäftigten
fehlen sandro auerbach ist personalchef
eines wiesbadener restaurants er spürte
sich der fachkräftemangel bereits
deutlich verschärft mehrere köche haben
trotz des kurzarbeitergeldes gekündigt
das restaurant hat nur am wochenende auf
es kommen wegen corona weniger kunden
aber es fehlt auch an personal so
personalmangel bei uns drastisch 30 bis
40 prozent des gesamten personals steht
uns nicht mehr zur verfügung abgewandert
in anderen branchen die krisensicher
sind viele unternehmen könnten nicht von
einem aufschwung nach der pandemie
profitieren die befürchtung dass wir nur
noch einen kleineren teil bestuhlen
können bzw bewirken können weil uns
ansonsten war das personal fehlt durch
corona könnte der fachkräftemangel auch
gesamtwirtschaftlich eine neue qualität
bekommen also grundsätzlich bedeutet
fachkräftemangel immer dass irgendwas
nicht erledigt wird und das kann
bedeuten dass jemand nicht vernünftig
gepflegt wird weil zu wenig leute da
sind das kann auch heißen dass wir kein
essen bestellen können weil das niemand
gibt er ist kocht es kann sein dass ich
ewig auf ein handwerker warte und ich
meine photovoltaik anlage nicht aufs
dach bekommen also im grunde zu wenig
leute bedeutet am ende auch in gewisser
weise eine mangelwirtschaft um die zu
vermeiden könnten die unternehmer
versuchen ihre ehemaligen mitarbeiter
mit besseren konditionen wieder
zurückzuholen
da kommt noch einiges auf uns zu wie
sieht sie also aus die deutsche
strategie in sachen corona wie weit
können wie weit sollten wir jetzt gehen
dazu viele fragen von wulf schmiese an
den bremer bürgermeister nachher hier im
heute-journal update und so viel zu
diesem thema hanna du hast jetzt einen
ersten überblick über weitere wichtige
nachrichten ja und da blicken wir auf
die neuen erkenntnisse nach den
tödlichen schüssen auf zwei polizisten
heute ist gegen zwei tatverdächtige
haftbefehl wegen mordes erlassen worden
sie sitzen in untersuchungshaft
die ermittler gehen davon aus dass beide
beschuldigten männer geschossen haben
und nannten als mögliches motiv die
vertuschung von wilderei gestern morgen
waren eine 24-jährige polizeianwärterin
und ihr 29 jahre alter kollege bei einer
verkehrskontrolle im rheinland
pfälzischen kusel erschossen worden
das bundesverfassungsgericht hat elf
verfassungsbeschwerden für mehr
klimaschutz auf landesebene nicht
angenommen geklagt hatten jugendliche
und junge erwachsene zusammen mit der
deutschen umwelthilfe
sie argumentierten dass ihre zukünftige
freiheit nicht geschützt werde die
bundesländer hätten die reduzierung von
treibhausgasen nicht gut genug geregelt
die karlsruher richter begründeten ihre
ablehnung unter anderem damit dass es
keine landesspezifischen maßgaben zur
co2 reduktion geben würde
er gilt als einer der bekanntesten und
gefährlichsten verbrecher deutschlands
nun muss sich der reemtsma-entführer
thomas drach erneut vor gericht
verantworten
der 61-jährige soll vier geldtransporter
überfallen und dabei zwei wachmänner
angeschossen haben ein mutmaßlicher
komplize ist in dem verfahren mit
angeklagt drach hatte 1996 jan philipp
reemtsma dem erben einer tabak dynastie
entführt und ein millionen lösegeld
erpresst dafür bekam er vierzehneinhalb
jahre haft
ein jahr nach dem militärputsch in
myanmar ist die lage dort weiterhin
instabil die un berichtet von folter und
sexuelle gewalt gegen die
zivilbevölkerung
mehr als 1500 menschen sollen seitdem
getötet worden sein tausende inhaftiert
gegner der militärherrschaft hatten am
heutigen jahrestag zu einem stillen
streik aufgerufen viele straßen blieben
leer und geschäfte geschlossen
vor einem jahr hatte das militär die
gewählte de facto regierungschef in
sanssouci entmachtet ihr drohen
jahrzehnte lange haftstrafe
zu sowjetzeiten war die kreml logi ein
ganzer berufszweig irgendwie erfahren
und verstehen was da hinter den roten
mauern am roten platz vor sich geht
aktuell sind kreml logan wieder gefragt
auch wenn deren treffsicherheit schon
damals nicht besonders hoch war was hat
wladimir putin vor das treibt die
internationale außenpolitik um warum
befiehlt er truppen aufmärsche von
historischer dimension und mit enormen
kosten an der grenze zur ukraine
die diplomatischen bemühungen eine
antwort auf diese frage zu finden und
schlimmeres zu verhindern füllen heute
terminkalender und regierungschefs mein
kollege florian hahn hat sich
stundenweise videomaterial von
gesprächen statements und
pressekonferenzen angesehen und dabei
besonders auf den russischen präsidenten
selbst geachtet
wenn es einen gradmesser gibt für die
kriegsgefahr dann vielleicht die zahl
der hochrangigen gäste die allein heute
nach kiew eilen um einen krieg zu
verhindern es kommt der britische
premier johnson davor der polnische
premier morawski zwischendrin eine
delegation des europäischen parlaments
und vorher schon der vizepräsident der
eu-kommission sie alle erklären der
ukraine ihre unterstützung mal mit
waffen mal mit geld mal mit worten wie
sauce unser besuch war auch ein zeichen
der unterstützung ein zeichen dass das
europäische parlament unerschütterlich
zur unabhängigkeit und souveränität der
ukraine steht independents
großbritannien unterstützt die ukraine
mit noch einmal 88 millionen pfund für
gute regierungsführung und
energieunabhängigkeit
wir sind bereit der ukraine
artilleriemunition raketen flugabwehr
leichte moerser aufklärungsdrohnen und
andere verteidigungswaffen zu liefern
die frage ist ob all das 800 kilometer
entfernt in moskau beeindruckt auch hier
kommt hochrangiger besuch viktor orban
aus ungarn der erste chef eines nato
mitglieds landes die in dieser krise zu
wladimir putin reist schon vorher hatte
man im westen sorge hier würde jemand
ausscheren zu recht wie sich zeigt aber
an erklärt sanktionsdrohungen des
westens mal eben für nonsens dabei
schlage die sanktionspolitik hat einen
umgekehrten effekt nicht den für den sie
vorgesehen war sanktionen sind ein team
scheitern verdammt es mitteln
wollte die putin mit zusagen belohnt
etwa für billiges gas es ist putins
erste öffentliche auftritt im konflikt
um die ukraine und er nutzt ihn für eine
abrechnung die usa würden die
sicherheitsinteressen russlands
ignorieren
ihr hauptanliegen ist dass die
entwicklung russlands zu behindern darum
geht es
dafür ist die ukraine nur ein instrument
ist kann auf unterschiedliche weise
erfolgen sehen sie uns in einen
bewaffneten konflikt
minute john elkann fliegt doch putin hat
eine zweite botschaft in dieser
pressekonferenz und sie lässt im westen
hoffen russland stehe bereit für
weiteren dialog morgen schon ist ein
telefonat mit dem britischen premier
johnson angesetzt der wiederum kein
zeichen von entspannung sieht
manch einer hat gesagt dass wir
übertreiben mit der bedrohung ist das
ist nicht wahr wir haben
geheimdiensterkenntnisse über weiteren
truppenaufbau ein einmarsch das ist eine
absolut reale gefahr
noch ist zeit für diplomatie die zahl
der kurzbesuch in kiew wird wohl nicht
weniger
russland hält nicht nur die usa gerade
in atem dabei wollte sich us präsident
joe biden eigentlich voll auf den
wirklichen weltweiten rivalen
konzentrieren und der sitzt nicht in
moskau sondern in peking gucken wir uns
das mal an china usa zwei supermächte
ringen um die vorherrschaft das zeigt
sich bei der zahl ihrer soldaten
das zeigt sich bei den jeweiligen
ausgaben für das militär jedes jahr
einsame weltspitze sind beide wenn es um
die wirtschaftsleistung geht der kampf
der alten supermacht mit der neuen läuft
nicht nur in den hauptstädten unser
washington korrespondent elmar theveßen
war für seine reportage ganz weit im
süden der usa
die wüste in texas nahe der
mexikanischen grenze noch in diesem jahr
wird ja eine bergkuppe abgesprengt eine
mine für seltene erden eröffnet denn das
gestein ist reich an beryllium thallium
und anderen metallen für die produktion
von mikrochips und batterien die
einwohner von zehra blanca freuen sich
auf die arbeitsplätze sie haben zwar
auch angst dass der tagebau luft und
trinkwasser verseuchen könnte trotzdem
sei es höchste zeit sagt uns bilder
denken dass amerika sich aus der
abhängigkeit von billiglohnländern wie
china befreit
all die firmen die seltene erden für
halbleitertechnik brauchen haben nur
eine quelle weil sie geld sparen wollen
ist vom billigsten anbieter kaufen
deshalb sind auch die lieferketten
zusammengebrochen weil sie keine
alternativen haben und alles nur in
übersee hergestellt wird
joe biden testet ein elektro hammer er
will amerikas technologischen vorsprung
sicherstellen und drängt us-konzerne
schnell sehr schnell ihre abhängigkeit
von china zu beenden die us wirtschaft
soll keinen schaden nehmen falls der
konflikt mit china
eskaliert
die lieferketten von allen sind sehr eng
mit taiwan und china verzahnt wenn es
also irgendeine geopolitische krise gäbe
hoffentlich natürlich nicht muss jeder
darauf vorbereitet sein deshalb soll uns
diese diversifizierung vor allen
problemen schützen die in einer region
entstehen in der die produktionsstätten
ziemlich konzentriert sind
also entstehen in phoenix arizona brand
neue fabriken für halbleiter und
mikrochips allein hier investiert intel
20 milliarden dollar noch einmal 20 für
ein weiteres werk in ohio es ist eine
wirtschaftliche und politische
kampfansage an china auf druck der us
regierung baut in arizona auch der
halbleiterproduzent tsmc aus taiwan für
12 milliarden dollar im benachbarten
texas der südkoreanische samsung-konzern
für 17 milliarden
wollen hier entsteht für rund zwei
milliarden dollar eine batteriefabrik
altium cells teil des versuchs wie china
die komplette herstellungskette im
eigenen land zu haben und amerikas
autoproduktion auf elektrofahrzeuge
umzustellen das notwendige lithium für
die batterien soll aus den usa selbst
kommen die produktion des rohstoffs wird
vervierfacht neben der batteriefabrik
trust einer die rivalität mit china
wirkte als konjunkturmotor der
arbeitsplätze schafft also ist die
stimmung gut bei den bauarbeitern
tischlern elektrikern sie wollen mit
verhindern dass china an amerika
vorbeizieht
die chinesen wollen ein imperium
schaffen sowie unseres das ist die
menschliche natur mit amerikanischem
einfallsreichtum und so lange wie
effizient und effektiv sind werden wir
weiter wachsen und dann bleiben wir für
immer die nummer eins
dafür springt amerika sogar berge ab
trotzdem ist längst nicht entschieden
wer am ende die nase vorn hat im duell
der supermächte zwischen china und den
usa
auf der chinesischen seite ist peking
korrespondent ulf röller an orte gereist
und hat mit menschen geredet die ginge
es nach der offiziellen propaganda
eigentlich niemand hören und sehen
sollte die beiden seiten zusammen
ergeben eine
faszinierende reportage über den kampf
der supermächte die rivalen china versus
usa bereits jetzt zu sehen in der zdf
mediathek und morgen haben dann im zdf
fernsehprogramm und hier bei uns nochmal
hanna und auch da geht es ums geld und
um eine meldung bei der alle hausbauer
ganz genau hinhören dürften und die die
es werden wollen nach dem vorzeitigen
aus der kfw förderung von
energiesparhäusern soll es nämlich nun
doch geld geben allerdings stefanie
beckert an der frankfurter börse nur für
diejenigen die bereits einen antrag
gestellt haben ganz genau kann er
aufatmen können alle die bis zum
stichtag 24 januar ihre anträge
eingereicht haben für sie ist der
fördertopf noch mal aufgestockt worden
alle erhalten die versprochenen
zuschüsse nach dem 24 januar gibt es
allerdings ein klaren schnitt danach
gehen häuserbauer des sogenannten
effizienzhauses 55 künftig ganz leer aus
bei tausenden von wohneinheiten fällt
damit die förderung nun weg das waren
bis zu 18.000 euro pro wohneinheit
dieses haus braucht zwar nur 55 prozent
der energie eines standard hauses es ist
aber inzwischen übliche baustandard
deshalb laut bundesregierung nicht mehr
förderwürdig die müssen sich ja
was ist denn mit den bauherren die sich
erst bald dazu entscheiden nachhaltig zu
bauen ja die müssen sich künftig
ambitionierte klimaziele setzen um in
den genuss von bundesförderungen
zukommen sanierungen und neubauten mit
dem standard e h 40 also gebäude die nur
40 prozent der energie von standard
häusern benötigen diese effizienteren
gebäude werden zwar noch bis zum
jahresende gefördert der fördertopf ist
aber gedeckelt entsprechend geringer
fällt die förderhöhe aus und damit nicht
genug ab 2023 soll dann ein ganz neues
förderprogramm für klimafreundliches
bauen aufgesetzt werden das dann
hoffentlich effizienten klimaschutz mit
effizientem einsatz von bundesmitteln
verbindet und nicht nur die schnellsten
belohnt vielen dank stefanie nach
frankfurt
18 stunden haben airbus und ig metall
verhandelt und das mit erfolg es gibt
eine einigung im mehrmonatigen streit
über den konzernumbau von airbus er kann
nun stattfinden allerdings müssen die
standorte erhalten bleiben und
betriebsbedingte kündigungen wurden bis
zum jahr 2030 ausgeschlossen
zehntausende jobs in deutschland sind
damit gesichert und auch die angedrohten
streiks sind vom tisch
und auch heute gibt es eine amtliche
unwetterwarnung der deutsche
wetterdienst warnt vor starkem
schneefall und schneeverwehungen im
südlichen bayern sowie vor orkanartigen
böen in teilen von sachsen und sachsen
anhalt
drei tage sind es noch bis zur eröffnung
der olympischen winterspiele und
mittlerweile ist ein großteil der
deutschen delegation in china angekommen
heute morgen landeten insgesamt 97
mitglieder der deutschen mannschaft am
flughafen von peking darunter etwa
skispringer karl geiger oder biathleten
denise herrmann
mit im gepäck ist dabei auch die angst
vor einer corona infektion am freitag
beginnen die spiele offiziell
und mit diesen bildern verabschieden wir
sie in die dienstagnacht und gegen 0.15
meldet sich hier wolfschmidt unserem
heute-journal update von uns allen hier
in redaktion und technik beim heute
journal an sie einen angenehm haben
[Musik]
schokolade und herzlich willkommen zum
wetter zu warm war der januar insgesamt
deutschlandweit war die abweichung 3,1
grad vom normal 1961 bis 1990 örtlich
aber durchaus deutlich mehr 4,8 grad wie
zum beispiel nach osten hin und es gab
zu wenig sonnenschein quer über
deutschland war es ziemlich trüb
teilweise kam nur 31 prozent der
sonnenscheinstunden zusammen aber nicht
so an den alpen hier schien die sonne
ziemlich lange wie man hier ganz gut
erkennen kann wir schauen auf die nacht
und da gibt es regen schnee und
graupelschauer die sich nach südosten
verlagern und sich vor allem wenn wir
erzgebirger aufstauen und hier schneit
es länger es gibt teilweise gewitter an
den alpen schneit es längere zeit ist es
recht windig und der schnee ist können
durchaus 50 zentimeter neuschnee an den
alpen runterkommen bei höchst über
tiefsten temperaturen von null grad im
vogtland minus 1 grad an den alpen und 7
grad ganz im westen deutschlands morgen
im tagesverlauf weitere schneefälle im
erzgebirge und am alpenrand dafür gibt
es im nordwesten sonnenschein ja auch
die temperaturen steigen auf höchstwerte
von drei grad richtung vogtland und 11
grad im rhein-main-gebiet die kommenden
tage sind weiterhin trübe mit regen
wenig sonne 4 bis 10 grad am donnerstag
freitag im norden dann regen uns
vielleicht am samstag dann vor allem
nach südwest nennt sonnenschein damit
ein schöner abend